Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Frau Schäkerl. Ich bin auch der Station als Assistentin tätig.
Heute möchte ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ja. Ich bin froh, dass Sie mir helfen wollen.
Okay. Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich schnell Ihre persönliche Daten fragen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Paul Müller.
Paul Müller.
Hein Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 noch.
Okay. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 18.09.54.
54. Okay. Hein Müller, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 m.
74.
Okay. Und kennen Sie, wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ja, das ist so immer um die 83 kg. Mal ein bisschen weniger, mal ein bisschen mehr, aber 83 kg kann man sagen.
Okay. Hein Müller, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentner zum Glück.
Rentner. Ah, okay. Ja, genau. Aber was haben Sie früher beruflich gemacht?
Ich war in der Stadtverwaltung angestellt.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich war Angestellter in der Stadtverwaltung.
Okay. Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind aber schon Erwachsenen.
Ah, okay. Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ja, zwei. Aber wie gesagt, die sind Erwachsenen.
Okay. Okay, Hein Müller. Was würdest Sie so ums? Wie kann Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also ich habe schon länger eigentlich so eine offene Stelle an meinem rechten Bein.
Und so innen am Knöchel und, naja, also das ist mal mehr und mal weniger groß.
Und jetzt in der letzten Zeit ist es aber wirklich immer mehr geworden.
Und also die Fläche wird immer größer und ich habe auch so das Gefühl,
die Wunde wird immer tiefer.
Und jetzt ist mir das vor dem Feiertag aufgefallen.
Und deswegen komme ich jetzt auch heute her.
Da läuft jetzt so komische Flüssigkeit raus, so braune Soße.
Und das war mir jetzt doch ein bisschen unheimlich.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich muss jetzt doch mal zu Ihnen hier in die Klinik kommen.
Ja, okay. Sie haben die gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, also das, das jetzt so nässt, das ist erst seit zwei, drei, ja, seit drei Tagen.
Seit drei Tagen.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, Unfall hatte ich nicht.
Haben Sie verletzt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Also irgendwann war das mit einmal da und dann habe ich halt gedacht,
ach, das heilt schon wieder von alleine.
Was, was ich vielleicht mal so ein bisschen mit dem Stiefel geschreuert am,
am Knöcheln habe ich so gedacht.
Aber ja, das ist jetzt schon ziemlich lange diese Stelle.
Und ja, wie gesagt, jetzt es tut auch ordentlich weh, muss ich sagen.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, sagte ich gerade, es tut weh, ja, das ist schmerzhaft, ja.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, die Wunde im Knöchel, aber wälte, rechte Bein, oder?
Am rechten Bein, am inneren Knöchel, ja.
Haben diese Beschwerden plötzlich begonnen?
Ja, also dieses Messen, das hat jetzt plötzlich begonnen.
Aber diese, diese Wunde, das hat sich so langsam entwickelt.
Ja, es war eine kleine Stelle und dann habe ich dann ein Pflaster drauf gemacht
und habe das eigentlich vergessen und dann ist die größer geworden
und habe ich ein größeres Pflaster drauf gemacht
und dann war es mal wieder ein bisschen eine Kruste drauf
und dann ging es wieder auf.
Und ja, jetzt ist es eben in den letzten Wochen immer mehr geworden, immer größer.
Diese Stelle jetzt ist es schon, also sagen wir mal, wie groß ist die,
das nimmt fast den ganzen Innenknöchel ein, ja.
Und ja, das sieht auch nicht so schön aus
und wie gesagt jetzt, dass das so die Flüssigkeit daraus läuft, das finde ich so ekelig, ja.
Okay.
Haben diese, haben ihre Schmerzen irgendwie aus?
Naja, das ist eigentlich auf diesem Wundbereich beschränkt, ja.
Ein bisschen außen rum, also ja.
Aber das ist ja doch schon auch ganz schön kräftige Schmerzen, ja.
Natürlich insbesondere, wenn man da irgendwie gegen kommt, ne?
Oder wenn ich den Fuß, also stark das Gelenk bewege, ja,
denn da ist Spannung drauf ist, dann tut es natürlich besonders weh.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Schmerzen oder Wunder, haben Sie bemerkt?
Hab ich ja gerade gesagt, wenn ich dagegen stoße, tut es mehr weh,
oder auch wenn ich das Gelenk, also in eine Richtung strecke, ja,
oder Beuge, also stark das Gelenk bewege, wobei das ist sowieso alles ein bisschen, ja,
das steht so unter Spannung, das ganze Gelenk oder der ganze Unterschenkel
ist eigentlich so ein bisschen dicker als normal.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen wieder beschreiben?
Nein, ich würde sagen, dass...
Stechen oder Brennen?
Also das Brennstechen beschreibt es schon ganz gut, ja.
Also ja, so dieses typische wie eben so eine offene Wunde wehtut, ne?
Wenn man dagegen kommt, dann vielleicht eher stechend.
Und wenn da irgendwas drauf kommt, vielleicht auch so so eben das, ja,
oder wenn ich da beim Abtrocknen dagegen komme, dass das so brennt,
wenn ich mir die Füße wasche.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Beinschwälung aufgefallen?
Ja, das Bein ist deutlich dicker, ja, ja, das ist mir schon aufgefallen.
Die Haut sieht auch ganz komisch aus, sie hat sich so ganz dunkel verfärbt,
also sie vergleicht den die Beine sehr verschieden aus.
Und haben Sie auch über die Wärme gemerkt?
Dass das wärmer ist, ich mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen,
aber heute ist es ja sowieso warm, ne?
Da sind die Beine wahrscheinlich beide warm.
Beide warm.
Ich denke beide Beine sind warm, weil heute warmes Wetter ist, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber, Hämmler?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, aber eigentlich nein, nein, nein, Fieber hab ich bestimmt nicht.
Leider sieht unter Nachts schweiß?
Nachtschwitzen tue ich eigentlich nicht, ne?
Also ich schlafe nicht besonders gut, aber schwitzen tue ich nicht immer nach, ne?
Seit wann können Sie nicht gut schlafen?
Och, das ist eigentlich schon lange, also bestimmt schon fünf Jahre oder so,
dass ich manchmal kann ich nicht gut einschlafen, manchmal wache ich nachts auf
und dann kann ich nicht wieder einschlafen.
Und manchmal wache ich früh morgens auf und bin da eigentlich noch müde,
aber so die, die schlafen ist schon seit längerer Zeit nicht so gut.
Gibt es letztens Gründe für Schlafstörungen?
Ach weiß ich nicht, bin halt alt, also schläft man vielleicht nicht mehr so gut.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder musst du Sie übel geben?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin ja nur wegen meines Fußes hier.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen, haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl im Bein gemerkt?
Taub ist das eigentlich nicht, nee, das tut nur weh und ich merke das,
dass das halt spannend, weil das ein bisschen geschwollen oder auch deutlich geschwollen ist,
aber Taub ist es nicht, nee, nee, Taub ist es nicht.
Haben Sie Missempfindungen in der, in Bein gemerkt?
Schmerzen habe ich, das ist eine deutliche Missempfindung, ja.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie krippeln?
Nee, also krippeln würde ich jetzt sagen, nee, nee, da kribbelt nichts in den Bein, nee, nee.
Okay.
Neben dieser Beschwelter gibt es noch etwas Symptoma neben dieser Beschwelter?
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie noch sagen wollen, also das ist eine Wunde,
wo so Flüssigkeit rausläuft und es trupft und es tut halt weh und natürlich tut eine Wunde am Bein weh, ja, ja, ja.
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 bewerten,
wenn 1 kaum Schmerzen sind, sehr stark ist der Schmerz, das bedeutet.
Ja, das ist schwer zu sagen, aber so in der Mitte würde ich das vielleicht einschätzen, so, da bei 5 dann, ne?
Okay.
Und kennen Sie diese Wunde oder diese Schmerzen, hatten Sie früher noch einmal?
Dass ich so eine offene Stelle hatte, hatte ich vorher noch nie, nein.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Müller, jetzt würde ich Ihnen nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leider sind Sie an chronischer Krankheit, wie Zuckerkrankheit, Blutdruck?
Ja, Blutdruck, also der Blutdruck, das weiß ich seit 10 Jahren, ist der Blutdruck ein bisschen hoch und außerdem habe ich ziemlich Probleme mit den Ohren.
Ich trage ein Hörgerät und da kriege ich immer wieder Mittelohrenzündungen und da hatte ich jetzt auch vor gar nicht so langer Zeit auch wieder Schmerzen und musste Medikamente nehmen,
aber das habe ich schon jahrelang, ja.
Seit wann tragt ihr diese Ohren, Gerät?
Also ich trage das so, ja, seit gut 4 Jahren und dann nach einem halben Jahr fing es an, dass ich das erste Mal deine Mittelohrenzündung hatte.
Okay.
Und Herr Müller, wurde Sie schon einmal operiert?
Hmm, nee, muss ich richtig überlegen, als Kind vielleicht, aber so viel ich weiß, nee, hatte ich nie eine Operation.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie leiden andere Tochter.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, also ich nehme Medikamente, ich weiß aber gar nicht, was davon gegen den Blutdruck ist.
Ich nehme, wie heißen die, einmal nehme ich HCT 25, da nehme ich morgens eine und dann nehme ich auch noch zufänobril, dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abitz.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Medikamente wiederholen?
Das eine ist HCT 25 und das andere ist zufänobril.
Und wie viel, wie viel Milligramm zufänobril?
Oh, das steht da drauf auf der Packung.
Ich meine, das steht 5 drauf, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Ich sehe die Packung so auf meinem Frühstück schliegen, glaub, ja, 5, ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie beide morgens ein?
Nehmen Sie zufänobril, nehme ich morgens und abends ein und das andere morgens.
Okay.
Okay, Hamila, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin gegen Corona, ja, da bin ich geimpft, aber das ist ja inzwischen auch schon eine ganze Weile her, die letzte Impfung.
Das ist schon bald, ja, ich glaube, da muss ich bald mal wieder hin, ja.
Aber ich habe da vier Impfungen bekommen.
Okay.
Hamila, haben Sie bestimmte Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, also, was ich nicht essen darf, das ist Fisch und Muscheln und Trimps und Langusten, also solche Meerestiere,
alle, das darf ich alles nicht essen.
Das kann ich überhaupt nicht vertragen.
Hab da einmal so eine starke Reaktion gehabt, dass ich keine Luft mehr bekommen habe, das ist aber schon lange her, aber seither pass ich da total auf.
Und dann reagieren meine Hände irgendwie, wenn ich so Handcreme benutze, da darf ich nur ganz bestimmte Handcreme benutzen,
alles, was so ein bisschen parfümiert ist, oder so, ja, so jukende Hautstellen auf den Händen.
Ich habe nicht gut verstanden, wenn Sie diese Handcreme benutzen, jucken Ihre Haut?
Ja, genau, also da darf ich nur ganz bestimmte Cremes, die ohne Allergiestoffe sind, die darf ich benutzen.
Okay, alles klar.
Und Hamila, rauchen Sie?
Oh, ich rauch jetzt schon viele, viele Jahre nicht mehr.
Ich habe aufgehört vor 18 Jahren und davor habe ich ordentlich geraucht, ja.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Das sind bestimmt 30 Jahre, da habe ich schon so ein Päckchen am Tag, da habe ich geraucht, ja.
Ein paar Kunsttäglich?
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, also, ja, ich trinke gelegentlich mal ein Bier jetzt im Sommer zum, um zu trinken.
Zum Abend hin oder auch wenn es etwas zum Feiern gibt.
Also am nächsten trinke ich Bier selten mal, fast nie eigentlich ein Schnaps oder so.
Überwiegend trinke ich eigentlich Bier, ja, aber auch nicht jeden Tag.
Können wir sagen, dass ich mal probo habe?
Ja, wenn man das so aufs Jahr rechnet, vielleicht ja.
Im Sommer eher ein bisschen mehr, im Winter, wenn ich halt trinke, ich eher kein Bier.
Okay, ja, alles klar.
Und die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Herr Müller, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen?
Ja.
Nein, wirklich nicht, nein, nein.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Müller, ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Familiengeschichte etwas fragen.
Eine Familiengeschichte, go do go do go, ja.
Neben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, nein, ich bin ja schon so alt, meine Eltern sind schon beide tot.
Tut mir sehr leid.
Woran sind Sie gestorben, Ihre Mutter und Ihre Vater?
Mein Vater, mein Vater, der hatte irgendeinen Krebs in den Gallenwiegen.
Ja, und ist daran letztendlich gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, die hatte irgendeine Darmerkrankung, ich weiß gar nicht, glaube,
Krebs hatte die nicht, aber die hat dann ein paar Jahre vor ihrem Tod
noch einen künstlichen Ausgang bekommen, aber die ist auch schon verstorben.
Aber die sind ja auch, wie gesagt, beide noch relativ alt geworden.
Okay.
Ihre Mutter litt an eine Darmerkrankung, aber Sie kennen nicht die Diagnose.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie genau hatte, nein, nein, ich weiß nur, dass sie da
so einen künstlichen Ausgang bekommen hat und ja, dass das halt das Gespräch war,
aber sie ist eigentlich damit ganz gut zurechtgekommen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay.
Sie haben zwei Kinder, sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, das will ich doch schwer hoffen.
Ja, also, meine, was alle mal haben, meine Grippe mal Schnupfen, mal Husten,
aber irgendwie große Erkrankungen haben die alle wirklich nicht.
Sehr gut.
Und wo sind Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Also mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja, wobei meine Frau ist auch sehr auf mich angewiesen.
Die ist rollstuhlpflichtig und braucht also schon ziemlich viel meine Unterstützung zu Hause.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Müller, machen Sie Sport?
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ich habe so ein bisschen Sport gemacht früher.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen Volleyball gespielt und ich bin auch ganz gerne Fahrrad gefahren,
aber jetzt in den letzten Jahren habe ich das nicht mehr gemacht.
Also Fahrrad fahren tu ich hin und wieder noch, aber eher so sehr gemütlich, nicht sportlich.
Okay.
Unser Gespräch ist fast alright, Herr Müller.
Möchten Sie hinzufügen oder etwas fragen?
Ja, ich will natürlich jetzt schon wissen, was man gegen dieses schmerzende Bein da machen kann
und ja, was da die Ursache ist und wie auch die Schmerzen besser werden.
Wissen Sie, meine Frau braucht mich nämlich, ja?
Und das kann ich mir nicht erlauben, krank zu sein.
Ja.
Das verstehe ich ganz genau.
Ich kann Ihnen vor der Urntelsuchung leider nicht so viel sagen,
aber ich würde jetzt Ihnen schmerzende Köpferlich untersuchen.
Danach können wir Ihnen Schmerzmittel geben und Sie fühlen sich besser.
Wir werden ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen, Danach.
Und alle Ergebnisse da sind, können wir besser sprechen und Ihre Diagnose stellen.
Ah ja, das verstehe ich.
Gut.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Ich frage immer.
Ja, seit 10 Jahren.
Haben Sie für Ihre Fußzehengelenk großrötiger geworden und Schwellungen?
Ob ich bemerkt habe, dass mein Zehengelenk geschwollen ist?
Ja, ja.
Ah ja, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Die ganzen Beine sind geschwollen, aber nicht das Zehengelenk.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Haben noch Kollegen?
Schützen will los.
Bitte schön.
Also, ich habe eine Frage.
Aber meine Frage ist ein bisschen komisch, ja.
Was ist das?
Also, konsumieren Sie irgendwelche Tierprodukte, zum Beispiel Öffene Milch oder
Fleisch oder kontaktieren Sie letztes Mal Fleisch oder Milch oder irgendwelche Tiere?
Sie meinen, ob ich irgendwie in der Verarbeitung, also entweder mit Tieren
beruflich zu tun hatte oder jetzt privat zu tun habe oder ob ich mit rohem Fleisch
und unverarbeiteter Milchkontakt habe?
Ja, ja, vielleicht besuchen Sie einen Bauernhof?
Im letzter Zeit, nein, nein, ich habe keinen Bauernhof besucht, nein.
Okay.
Ich muss nachher unbedingt fragen, warum Sie das gefragt haben.
Müssen wir nachher noch mal darüber sprechen?
Ja, okay, ich habe so meine Idee.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Sind Sie in Lesterzeit ins Auslands gereist?
Nein, wissen Sie, meine Frau ist rollstuhlpflichtig zu Hause und braucht meine Hilfe
und so reisefähig sind wir nicht in die Einigung.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie in Lesterzeit Grippe oder Infektion?
Ob ich Grippe hatte?
Nein, die Grippe hatte ich nicht.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe eine kleine Empfang, die ich hier habe.
Ich habe eine, die bei der Kollegin ist.
Wie weit sie ist, ob sie meinen, sie können schon loslegen.
Afsa.
Empfang?
Ja.
Okay.
Was war mal ein bisschen schwer?
Was? Was war schwer?
Schade oder Schade?
Es hat nicht so gewirkt, als ob es schwer war.
Sie haben super gefragt und sehr vollständig und sie waren sehr nett zu Herrn Müller
und haben auch sehr konkret nachgefragt.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das richtig schwer war für Sie.
Also jetzt machen wir mal Art und Art Gespräch, ja?
Okay.
Darf ich anfangen?
Ja.
Guten schönen Abend Frau Oberatzin.
Ich würde Ihnen unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Den haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, er heißt Paul Müller.
Paul Müller ist 69 Jahre alt, 1,74 m, groß und 83 kg.
Er ist schwer.
Ja, schwer.
Herr Müller kann Sie uns wegen nassender Ulzeration am unterstecken
und Sie, pardon, er bericht eine offene Wunde.
Diese Wunde seien seit einem, seit einem Woche begonnen
und seit Mittelszeit, seit Mittelszeit starker geworden.
Außer dem Klack der Überschweinöderung und die Entschuldung sei hin,
wie Überschweinung, Dünke, Farbveränderung und Wundsekret.
Bei Bewegung sei ein bisschen schwer geworden,
außer dem Klack, außer dem Bericht der Unserpatienten
sind alle schwer.
Diese schweren Wunde sind 5 Möller, 10 Möller.
Schmerz Intensteit League auf Nummer 6 Schmerzskala
bei fünf Konzen und ja, früher hatte unser Patient diese Beschwerden nicht.
Wir sind unerfällig, Fragen nach Fieber und nach Schweiz wurden verneint.
Ich habe seit ungefähr fünf Jahren in Somnia sowohl ein als auch durchschlafen, habe ich Störungen.
Die anderen vegetativen Anämpfeln sind unaufwähig, außer sie sind Fragen nach neurologischen Zeichen unaufwähig.
An Vorerkrankungen sind arteriale Hypertonyne und Hirschtörungen bekannt.
Seit zehn Jahren ist er arteriale Hypertonyne und dagegen nehme ich die HACT 25 mg ein Mal morgens und zufähig 5 mg ein und ein Mal morgens und ein Mal abends.
Seit 18 Jahren ist er nicht rauperin, aber früher haben er 30 Jahre lang ein Packungstegelig geraucht, das entspritzt 30 Packungsjahren, Drogenkonsum für den Verneid.
Bei der Familienanamnese ergab sich Folgendes, ihr Vater ist am Gallen-Karsinum gestorben und ihre Mutter, der Patient ist ein Mann immer noch.
Die Mutter ist am Gallen-Karsinum gestorben, aber der Patient weiß nicht, ob sie unklar ist.
Meine Verdacht Diagnose lautet Ulkes Kurius Venous.
Die Diagnose kommt von der Corona-Schweinung und die Diabetische Fuß in Betracht.
Die Diabetische Fuß und Fuß, ja?
Ja, die Diabetische Fußsendung.
Und das könnte es noch sein unter Umständen?
Wie bitte?
Was könnte es alternativ sein, wenn es nicht chronische Indifizienz ist?
Was könnte es noch sein?
Es könnte ja auch ein...
Was könnte die Ursachen fürs Ulkos noch sein?
Könnte auch ein ategelles Ulkos sein?
Ja.
Also nicht nur Venous, es könnte auch ein ategelles Ulkos sein, ne?
Ja, genau.
Gut, was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ja, diagnostisch würde ich so erst körperlich untersuchen und danach Laboruntersuchung ist nötig.
Entzündung, Parameter, WCRP, BCG und die andere Laborwerte, Blutbild.
Das sind die Laborwerte.
Aber worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Da müssten wir erst mal noch ein bisschen gucken, was unternehmen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Perfekt, ich kontrolliere Perfektarterie, Perfektpusse.
Perfektarterie?
Perfektpusse und Entzündung, Seichen, kann ich kontrollieren.
Ja.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ich kann kontrollieren, ob die Patienten alles gut bewegen.
Ja, ich meine noch etwas anderes.
Er hat ja gesagt, nur das Arzt meines Geschwollens sagt er.
Also müssen Sie erst mal gucken.
Inspektion, danach Perfektion.
Ja, und unter Umständen auch Umfangsvergleich.
Ja.
Nach der Laboruntersuchung kann ich Ronskern für Unterbein durchführen.
Ronskern?
Ja.
Warum?
Ich kann mich nicht gut erinnern, aber es könnte eine Verletzung sein und außer dem Ja.
Also es gibt ein Verfahren, das deutlich weniger aufwendig ist und auch keine Strahlenbelastung hat.
Was würde man sicherlich zuerst machen?
Du bleibst Sonografie?
Ja, genau.
Du bleibst Sonografie der Beinwebenden?
Ja, durch Du bleibst Sonografie können wir Diagnose stellen.
Dann wissen wir, ob es ein venöses Unkurs ist.
Oder eben im Vorfeld, wenn Sie schon festgestellt haben, die Fußpulse sind nicht da,
dann wäre der Verdacht auf ein atelierlles Unkurs.
Dann würde man trotzdem dublech sonografisch gucken, wo ist da eine Winderdurchflutung?
Ja.
Gut.
Was würde man möglicherweise auch noch machen?
Für Therapie oder Diagnostik?
Nein, Diagnostik.
Denken Sie mal an den Kollegen, der nachgefragt hat, ob ich auf dem Bauernhof war.
Also ich dachte, es könnte Antrag sein, Scharbon, kennen Sie?
Ich habe etwas anderes gedacht.
Ich habe gedacht, dass heute alle Landwirte und Schlachtiere MRSA haben.
Also in den Oxyzellin-Resistenten Staphylococcus aureus.
Das ist mit Corona ein bisschen in Hintergrund geraten.
Aber ein Wundabstrich würde man eigentlich machen, wenn jemand mit einem langen Dauer
in den Urkurs kommt, damit man sehen kann, was das für ein Keim drauf ist.
Das wäre meine Idee.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, Sie fragen danach.
Ich erinnere mich, das ist jetzt schon ein paar Jahre her, dass wir aber tatsächlich zur Frage,
ob jemand einen Wundabstrich in MRSA bekommt, dass wir im Vorfeld gebracht haben, pflegebedürftige Angehörige,
Kontakt im pflegeheimen Pflegeberuf, Landwirte.
Es gab noch ein sagtvoll anderer Fragen, wo man, oder natürlich auch immer,
langdauernde chronische Wohnen.
Da haben wir Coronaabstriche, haben wir MRSA-Abstriche veranlasst.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, da geht Ihre Frage hin.
Und Sie sagen Antrags?
Ja, Antrags.
Muss ich nachgucken?
Also es ist sehr beckern in der Türkei.
Deswegen dachte ich, dass Antrag sein könnte.
Mir sagt, ich muss das tatsächlich raussuchen.
Kann ich jetzt so nicht beantworten.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gut, also Abstrich wäre ja noch eine Sache.
Gut.
Ja, wie würden Sie den Patienten jetzt weiter behandeln?
Für Behandeln können wir zunächst Analgetikungen geben,
dann für lokale Wunderapie und gegebenenfalls Kurethage ist nötig.
Kompressions-
Ja, okay.
Aber gegebenenfalls.
Kompressions-therapie ist nötig für diese Patiente.
Sehr gut.
Ach, ja, okay, jetzt weiß ich.
Ja, also ist hier, ah, kann das sein,
weil in der Türkei Katzen sehr häufig frei rumlaufen?
Kann das sein, dass sie deswegen eine hohe Infektionsvater haben?
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Also wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass das hier eine Rolle spielt,
aber hier, ah ja, wir kriegen ständig neue Informationen.
Ja, wer weiß, wie vielleicht wieder eine neue solche auf dem Weg
oder eine alte, die auflackert,
aber ihr MRSA sagt Ihnen allen was, oder nicht?
Ja.
Also, das ist ja eigentlich der gefürchtete Krankenhauskeim,
dass Leute praktisch mit irgendeiner Bagatelle in die Klinik kommen
und hinterher mit einem resistenten Keil wieder nach Hause gehen
und kränker sind als vorher.
Aber für die FSB müssen wir leichter in die Diagnose denken.
Bisschen wir leicht in die Diagnose denken?
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja, also jedenfalls sind wir bei unserem Ulkos sicherlich auf
richtigen Weg, ja klar.
Wir haben auch sofort, was man tun muss mit den Patienten,
also hinterher Grundthera, lokale Grundtherapie, Kompression
und natürlich im Zweifelsfall, wenn sie, wenn es sich rausstellt,
dass dann eine wenige Inseffizienz ist, kann man dann auch erstmal
die Grunderkrankung behandeln, indem man also eine Sklerosierung
oder eine Venicherologie macht, ne?
Okay.
Ja, wir sind schon leicht so ein bisschen in der Manöverkritik.
Sie, Sie haben das sehr schön gemacht, muss ich erst mal sagen.
Also wirklich war eine schöne Anamnese
und Sie haben auch einen schönen systematischen Bericht gemacht.
Sie haben einige wenige Sachen nicht ganz korrekt wiedergegeben.
Und zwar, der hat gesagt, er hat schon monatelang eine kleine, offene Stelle.
3 Tage. Bitte?
3 Tage und Sie haben...
Seit 3 Tagen nesti.
Die Stelle ist schon seit Monaten und ist, ne?
Er hat die immer behandelt, ja, er flasche drauf und also
jetzt ist sie größer geworden, ja?
Und das ist schon eine lange Geschichte.
Und das hat er auch so gesagt und er hat gesagt, jetzt ist es größer und tiefer.
Also die Wunde hat sich vergrößert und ist auch tiefer geworden.
Und seit 3 Tagen nest die Wunde, ne?
Das war diese Geschichte.
Dann könnte man das natürlich doch ein bisschen genauer präzisieren,
dass man eben nicht sagt am Unterschenkel, sondern eben am Innenknöchel.
Das ist natürlich auch so eine klassische Stelle für ein Ulcus.
Ja, genau.
Oder ich schreibe schon...
Bitte?
Ja, da ich schreibe schon unter Extremität medialen Mallor.
Mallor.
Medial Mallor.
Ja, dann Augenblick, was war noch?
Du, du, du, du, du.
Genau, protientes Rentner.
Ach ja, genau.
Sie haben ihn gefragt, ob das Bein überwärmt ist, hat er verneint.
Sie haben aber gesagt, Erzündungszeichen hätte er geschildert.
Ja, aber...
Ja, dann hat er gesagt, es ist warmes Wetter und die Beine sind sowieso warm.
Er hat auch nicht ausdrücklich gesagt, dass das Bein wärmer ist als das andere.
Das wäre sowas, was man im Rahmen der Untersuchung feststellt.
Er hat gesagt, das Bein ist geschwollen, er hat Spannungsgefühl.
Und auch, dass es verfärbt ist.
Das sind natürlich alles Erzündungszeichen, ne?
Ja, das sind auch Erzündungszeichen.
Ich möchte eine Hinzige sagen, dass eine Erzündungszeichen,
die ich vorhin gesagt habe, war, nein, nein,
welche Erzündungszeichen, Dollar, Color, Tomor, Rubor,
und Funktion Lazia, Leisia,
deswegen der Patient hat eine Funktion Lazia.
Deswegen, wir müssen nicht sagen,
keine Erzündungszeichen.
Aber hat sie auch nicht gesagt, sie hat gesagt,
Entzündungszeichen hat er beschrieben.
Und sie hat die drei eben aufgeführt.
Und ich habe gesagt, ne, die Überwärmung hat er nicht geschildert.
Also, sie hat es eigentlich, sie hat es schon richtig formuliert,
die Kollegin, aber sie hat eben die, die Entzündungs,
sie hat eben die Überwärmung mit aufgeführt,
obwohl der Patient die eigentlich verneint hat.
Sie hat nicht gesagt, wurden verneint.
Verneint wurden neurologische Störungen, ne?
Oder, oder, was haben sie, ja, irgendwie, ja,
das haben sie so, so bestätigt.
Und, und beschrieben.
Und das war ja auch so auf die Frage, ob er Kribbelparistisien hat
oder Lähmungserscheinung hat er gesagt, nie habe ich nicht.
Okay. Also, ich würde schon sagen, sie haben weitgehend
eine sehr, sehr konkrete Darstellung gemacht.
Und, was sie den Patienten nicht ausdrücklich gefragt haben,
was er aber bestätigt hätte,
der hatte vor Jahren mal eine tiefen Thrombose rechts.
Ja, und das wäre vielleicht noch so etwas,
wo man bei einem Verdacht auf ein venüses Urlkurs,
könnte man da nochmal nachfragen.
Sie haben also auch nicht explizit dann weiter gefragt,
als er, als er erzählt hat von seinem Ohren
vom Blutdruck, gibt es noch weitere oder gab es in letzter Zeit
noch weitere Erkrankungen, dann hätte er das vielleicht noch erzählt.
Okay.
Nur, aber sonst bin ich eigentlich völlig bei Ihnen.
Ja, gut.
Und ich denke, Sie haben das, Sie haben das schön gemacht.
Und ja, selbst den Düsseldorfer Prüfer
und der Düsseldorfer Prüfer.